schwierig finde ich trotzdem so zu sagen
was die versammlungsfreiheit angeht da
verbote durchzusetzen
auch verbunden damit dass der
innensenator ja gesagt hat dass
verschwörungs und biologen keine bühne
geboten werden darf das ist sozusagen
eine inhaltliche analyse ich hätte mir
da sozusagen er eine der struktur
gewünscht also die veranstaltung in
hanau die sie angesprochen haben die ja
auch abgesagt wurde ich glaube da ist es
deshalb nicht so öffentlich diskutiert
von weil der veranstalter auch damit
einverstanden war weil die veranstalter
gesagt habe aufgrund der aktuellen
zahlen die vorlegen sehen wir dass
selbst ein und es gab eine stille
gedenken eine stelle eine kleine
gedenkveranstaltung also der
veranstalter selbst hat diese
entscheidung mitgetragen trotzdem waren
sehr viele natürlich verstimmt haben
sich in ihrer würde war auch gekränkt
gefühlt und haben es überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen können
es war mit der anstalt ist dass das
natürlich eine eine frage die ist auch
berechtigt keine frage diese trotz es
geht ja jetzt ein bisschen auch um diese
demo und fakt ist einfach die haben sie
schon mal daneben benommen und wenn sich
jemand daneben benimmt sich nicht an
regeln hält dann muss man eine
konsequenz daraus ziehen sonst macht das
jeder sehen kann ich finde es viel
aushalten ja damit demokratie
das müssen auch die demokratie feinde
die inhalte aushalten des opfers auch
überhaupt keine inhaltlichen sein geht
sie darauf dass überhaupt nicht geben
sondern wie gesagt ich darf mit dem logo
durch die stadt sehen und darf alles
mögliche vertreten auch was
wissenschaftlich nicht fundiert es
überhaupt gar kein thema da muss die
demokratie mit umgehen können das können
wir auch was anderes ist wenn ich
gesundheit gefährden dadurch dass ich
schon als veranstalter sage keine masken
laufen sind zwar abstand halten aber
keine masken aufziehen das beim letzten
mal auch schon mal durch gezogen wurde
und dann ja auch aufgelöst wurde
ich denke das kann daraus kann man schon
den rückschluss ziehen dass es auch
diesmal wieder so geschieht und wenn sie
sich mal die die unterstützer im netz
auch anschauen da gibt es ganz viele die
sagen wir gehen auf keinen fall maske
also auch diejenigen die teilnehmen
wollen ich glaube das alles muss dann
auch berücksichtigung finden in dieser
güterabwägung also muss ich jetzt
wirklich zulassen dass leute die andere
gefährden wollen das muss ich ja
was letztlich das man ja fast schon
unterstellen also mindestens grob
fahrlässig
da muss man nicht dass es geht also für
mich gibt es in dieser frage darf es
auch nicht um den inhalt gehen den
inhalt müssen wir aushalten
aber wenn es dazu führt dass all diese
menschen nach hause gehen und dann
andere wieder infizieren und die werden
dann ist dieser güterabwägung denke ich
durchaus nachvollziehbar dass hier so
entschieden wollte
[Musik]